those fingers with a delicious chip
butty
the secret of a good chip butty is in
the potato now these are désirée
potatoes one of my first ever jobs was
working in a chip shop nice to put sacks
and sacks of potatoes into the rumbler
which will send the potato peeler all
day long today I'm gonna do something a
bit healthier for my oven chips with a
twist simply peel slice and blanch for
three to four minutes drain season and
cover well with paprika spread evenly
over an oiled baking tray and place into
a preheated oven for 20 minutes simple
as that
next up easy fish fingers this is
Pollock a really nice firm delicious
fish got the fish and finger size
patterns of fish put them onto your
plate and just lightly salt them you can
do that literally 20 minutes 30 minutes
before you start cooking the fish it
firms the fish up beautifully and it
allows it to become a little more
durable especially in the pan now for
the coating start by thoroughly coating
the fish in seasoned flour and then just
roll it to get rid of those little sharp
corners because then it stops those
corners almost burning in the pan in
curate wash and really coat them
wonderful and then this is dill goes
brilliant well with a fish and run the
deal through my breadcrumbs that makes
it more aromatic Haven
on to your breadcrumbs nothing wrong
with the chip butty nothing wrong with
fish fingers
just give it a lovely modern twist
beautiful once the fish fingers are
thoroughly coated they're ready to pan
fry and they'll need around three
minutes on each side all the fish
fingers will be nice and crispy get a
really nice color on them first and then
we'll flip them over and finish them
with butter bring the heat up into the
pan nice little knob of butter that
worked wonders with the breadcrumbs in
the deal nice and carefully check them
out they look smell incredible
so nice and crispy now to assemble my
chip butty starting with buttered big
crusty bread
[Music]
it's nice and wet mop up that amazing
flavor on slice in half
never slice in an angle my mouth is
salivating beautiful on weather ship but
E there's one thing missing and it
signifies that I've never forgotten the
joy I've come for food but my god that
makes me feel like a nine-year-old
excuse me for a moment we want to stuff
my face
[Applause]
homemade fish fingers and my ultimate
chip butty so simple to make but trust
me it tastes amazing
now the secret to whisking is a big
beautiful balloon whisk the bigger the
blue that needs sliding down juicy and
creamy tender